and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review watch
who are you
you mean while you think you Bureau me
oh there's a man cobra shake and he
fights criminals by distracting that
with his face tell me what my face looks
entirely and they appear with Jewish
ative whatever that means and it's blue
kidnap anybody he won because everybody
is distracted by his tribe talking
seriously doesn't the guy pull out any
pants my penis is beautiful too but you
don't see me plotting it around ok ok
once or twice every Tuesday so the
Watchmen are out to stop the evil
version I was arrested once only they
said it wasn't Jewish enough for me
there was a breakfast it was a Russian
brothel I uncle down on you for 20 volts
it is about to unleash the Cold War this
one superhero is like I understand the
Russian from blowing up America 3
because I ain't gonna blow it up first
so they're trying to stop the evil
superhero for blowing up New York and
heroes are like you can't throw up New
York City and the villain is like crap
so it turns out that superheroes aren't
really that super one superhero blows up
New York another like you is women and
children and the last one just flashes
everybody so we're heroes never cease
man going around flashing everybody
though it's outfit does be very little
to the imagination
I thought superheroes were supposed to
save the day but these heroes are like
when we did seed the wheel just half of
me okay that's bullcrap is what happened
but man was here that's right
there's a but man he needs yourself of
Superman Batman in Santa Clause any
bombers on evildoers above man in fact
you keep a secret I pop nobody knows cuz
I'm not wearing my glasses or has my
traditional theme music you see the only
downside is now that you know I'm gonna
have to kill you no I'm just kidding
I just made you impotent unlike the
naked Blue Man Group how do you wish to
sit this is Jerry Busey come on put you
in touch with my anchorman thanks the
games will cover them